the Civic sweet please do not delay your
evacuation collect any belongings and
please do not return to the building and
given to a given permission to do so by
council staff can I remind everyone that
this meeting is being recorded and will
be broadcast on the public access on our
own website you can do course that would
not include the the exclusion side of it
because obviously that Polly's pnc right
starting with apologies for absence
please I think every lovely given our
apologies I think that's old normal is
attending we have counsel Stanley and
council booty if that can be noisy
please minutes of the meeting held on
the first of June but what happens is
the first union that I have your
agreement that I saw them as a true
recordings inquiry okay and any any
messes and we want to answer those okay
right declarations of interest if any if
anybody comes across and the interesting
they weren't aware of during the meeting
please declaring then and we'll make a
note of it matters because the executive
and reports from other communities there
are another on the way so we go straight
to item 6 which is the financial out
turn management report which is yep you
know right are you are you doing this on
that force or no please I'll get food
please do you know if
what the report shows is part of a
journey it's a journey that the whole
council has been on it's not necessarily
a smooth journey and it's not
necessarily a famous journey but a long
journey you you do if you hopefully have
one or two successes and I think this
out running board that describes certain
success along this long and long journey
we have achieved the targets that we
reset in terms of saving money and in
terms of putting ourselves on it
financially on route towards are
financially sustainable footing however
it shouldn't be seen as as the end of
the journey there is still a number of
years where we know that the funding
coming in our direction is not going to
meet a planned expenditure or what we
would like to be our planned expenditure
and so we must remember that the jerk
jerk needs to continue we need to look
at every bit of spending that we do
however you can see through the report
how opposition had has temporarily
improved there is one one small
operation that I would like to put
forward before Matt can go into some of
the detail if you if you like right and
start one by one and this mention of
transfer of two general balances to
allow us to continue on our journey I'd
like a small amendment to that to move
into general balance sufficient money to
make sure that we need to the sit for
guidelines with the remainder of that
some going into the transformation and
innovation in more preserves to allow
the cow
to continue to move forward with its
innovations and possibly the setting up
of some commercial ventures and thank
you I own foot figure on that at the
moment because some of the figures that
we have are flowing we know the set of
guidelines are good car I don't think
always it's Tim center exit area
subverts if we recommend that your
general fund reserve is ten percent of
budgeted expenditure or hopefully at
least it's a bit better than ten percent
so we would probably be looking to move
around about three or four hundred
thousand into the transformation has
been right don't we do we have to define
that within this meeting or can be put
it in those terms now what more would
happen is the current set of accounts
are yet to be audited so following the
next tournament for most and young
completing in the end of August being in
September we can then move it following
that event just a very mountain right
okay all right any questions please
members or comments on the on the report
think it is a good report I think it
outlines as councillor Smythe's airliner
journey relating to how we are actually
looking at our expenditure where we can
cut costs we have where we think there
may be expenditure that is over and
above which the only about that as we
planned at all let me know every line
unfortunately mixes but it's an go over
some go under so hopefully going forward
we can maintain that but of course you
know there's an awful lot of challenges
coming for us and I think that's
mentioned within the report as well and
of course going forward we need to make
sure that we cover ourselves and do the
things that we want to do as far as our
services and our residents are concerned
and I think this is a good grounding for
that going forward you know
the sort of foundation is built should
we say but we've got to get some of the
bricks in place and we're not anywhere
near building a roof over again can I
just have one more thing chairman if I
may just point out that appendix 3 the
capital projects carried forward there
in addition to the capital projects this
year as well thank you very much ed
sorry is it yourself change isn't
something I was cotton Thank You Jerry
you know with regard to this it was soon
to me that you know bearing in mind that
you know we have uncertainties going
forward over the next few years it seems
to be reasonably cautiously I say
cautiously optimistic outlook the killer
Smith agreement liana predicting the
future is a challenge if i had a car my
car car really say any more than that
some have that there are a lot of
uncertainties we do need to be cautious
and i think over the next six months we
will get a clear indication of direction
of travel thank you i think that as i
said from the beginning do you think of
what's happened in the country since the
first of june you know which is a single
lifetime oil doesn't it and it's still
happening as we speak you know it's it's
a difficult to predict where we'll be in
certainly in four or five years so what
funds will be available
you know outcomes will be so I think we
have to accept it that's a time to be
grateful I do thank the staff for all
the work they put into this as well
because I think they've done a sterling
job for us on that so thank you very
much indeed yes please trimming you know
working working on my portfolio now with
its my assistant director I mean that
there seems to be another continuing
list of potential areas of saving but
when can we get to the stage are we ever
going to get to the stage where we can
actually say well actually we can cross
some of these off because as you suppose
we're all very much aware there are
going to be times when we're going to
have to make some very very difficult
situations but when we can have to start
making those difficult situation I'm
very nice a catch-22 but I we're looking
to my commitment for the next year or
longer if we are looking at contracts
and one thing another well how can we
know where we're going well commitments
with the motor contrary me you know we
keep seeing this is a whole list here of
potential this is an area you should
consider for savings well we can't do
everything and take on board new
contracts I think in terms of this
report this this is a backward look at
the you just close but obviously we have
in place at the moment the current
and financial strategy which highlights
a 170,000 pounds worth of concepts in
this year that still needs to be
developed and delivered with a male part
of the overall 3 million pound budget
gap over the next five years now
obviously that 870,000 movie looked at
over the coming weeks as the 2017 budget
process begins and they may be elements
of that that will come up for discussion
and new areas would need to be do
consider saying that the 3 million pound
is still very real and it's a it's a
saving this still needs to be achieved
over over the cycle and obviously during
this year we'll be adding another year
to that cycle I was sitting there today
I've just thinking through some of the
uncertainties going forward and maybe
just the kind of emphasize some of some
what's already been said tonight you
know we I we're being told to expect an
interest rate cut this month to possibly
25 possibly even 0% that will impact the
whole budget process in terms of
inflation that we build in in particular
around a treasury management investment
stream brexit and where and how article
50 will being put through when them take
place and what impacts that will have an
autumn statement with whoever is going
to be the Chancellor of the Exchequer in
this year and what steer that will bring
on local government will we be in
recession by the end of this year and
then that I guess that the top of the
iceberg is the business rates and what's
going to happen with one hundred percent
business retention going for
towards the end of the Parliament so
it's a cliche we keep saying and there
are lot of uncertainties but they are
uncertainties and and all we can do now
is build that foundation and put things
in place so we can meet nice demands as
and when they come forward I think one
of the things we've always tried to do
is to look at the worst position
absolutely as you look at the worst
position then at least you're covering
yourself if you like as far as the
future is concerned but having said that
and I think you know this this report is
an example where you can actually plan
for something I didn't actually make
further savings even within that but
there's only so much you can do and what
we've done here we probably won't be
able to do next year and probably even
less the year after that you have to be
very careful about how we manage that
you follow me in that that money that we
have but I think there are certain
things if you like them in it and it's
in the gift of members but if there are
certain projects they want to go ahead
with that can be accommodated within the
budget will left that's okay but it's
got to be really well planned for and I
think it's got to be makes make sure
that we we're in a position where we can
cover that within our budget but it's
you know it's keeping you know it's
literally keeping your head above water
for the iceberg Matt mentioned I mean
four pieces of it i Function you can't
say and I buy it I am I fully accept
that Jennifer think you'll agree on that
yeah but I mean I've done I don't I
don't want us to want us I know the
counselors got taking responsibility but
if you always look at the gloomy aside
forever and you worked this could be the
worst scenario you end up putting
yourself almost into a very negative
view point that you're not prepared to
do anything because it's fear of a bit
not happening if you exactly
yeah yeah I appreciate that and it's a
very real challenge but I think also we
need to remind ourselves that in the
current business plan that was agreed by
members used to become financially
self-sufficient and all of this is
putting those building blocks in place
to achieve line we may reach the stage
Hyrum you know I mean freezes preps is
an example some of us on a governess
city etc and you know I I can bring it
on up sectors before we are so today I
think comes down to one word which is
confidence and I think there's an awful
lot of things out there where people
have knocked down the confidence on the
air country but there are real
opportunities captioning that earlier
and I think that somebody needs to know
of some problems needs to stand up and
say or just like they did before we all
voted these are the real opportunities
that are in front of them separately and
I think it's about grasping those
opportunities and taking them forward
but you know something at county council
yesterday somebody was talking about the
grants that we get from the european
union and where will they stay we'll
never get me pay for those from here we
go and we get less than half way back i
think it is it's certainly not all of it
back and of course there will be the
heck control of our Parliament our
country not in the control of another
organization there in hoses real
conditions on that and decides where
that money will go or we can actually
decide that and we'll have probably a
bit more of it to spend as well so these
these are opportunities in whatever me
my video and going forward I'd like to
think perhaps a little bit of that some
will come halfway I'd like to think but
I think that's down to the government
and how we could Lobby the new
chancellor who ever it will be I can
tell you they are something right now
it's really happened yeah time to catch
me a few comments on the things to post
I don't want to repeat what what's been
said that look you know that your
destiny is in your own hands you know
and i think the business plan is in a
very clearly road map to the ambitions
for the commercial projects and other
issues that you need to think very
carefully about in terms of ensuring
that you know there is a long-term
future for the council the position at
the moment is really is really the cloud
reason one well that doesn't mean you
know it's not talking about charities
that doesn't mean that you know people
people stay that way but the way that we
can you know give the budget every
chance of continuing to be tip tip to be
a good one is by bringing forward than
the various projects you know that are
identified in the business plan clearly
members have used about whether many of
those those projects are ones that they
want to pursue whether they really are
realistic and so on means that we need
to have a dialogue about what
alternatives that the PM
because I think it's important that we
we don't just so you know start saying
well we'd not let will not do that or
this isn't going to work you know I
think it's a question of saying well if
we're not going to do something then
what is the alternative and that's the
key questions that we ask and we'll be
having that dialogue as we as we we go
through the other end of this year and
into the next and into the next budget
cycle mayonnaise and so I don't
hopefully have what we are in a position
where I'm at the moment we have no
borrowing whatsoever and there's not
many cancers like that but basically we
don't have a lot of reserves either but
at least we're not in a position where
we react to repay capital my interest as
well but it's something we need to
consider your future projects okay now
I'll be God's sake now as Matt mentioned
it this is looking bad backwards
certainly but where we are there's this
plenty of rope of reason to have some
optimism thank you and we must remember
that as councils go we've done a lot of
hard work that have to lot of pain long
before the council's and I think some of
those the Council of authorities again
suffered worse than us as a mentioned at
the start we are building our are
transformational innovation so we have
got the the opportunity to to invest
invest to say investor generate income
and and of course as always we're
looking to start our budget setting
process as early as possible we've got
dates in the diary for way days are
traditional form that have started to
look at
and yes it is in the gift deserves as
members to determine what our priorities
are it members set a particular set of
priorities then we need to look how we
can fall for film does so I think I see
part of part and roll to make it clear
where where we're going and to make it
absolutely clear to people have the
money stacks up but nevertheless there
is a way forward this is part of that
way forward okay yeah I'm 529 think you
like to challenge some of the things in
this next week vehicle but some I see no
other indications did you watch me talk
sorry now that's what I thought you so
much after you general we've all got a
cop at the bottom of the road once it
that will hay fever right so as far as
the recommendations are concerned bear
in mind the amendment i think that
counselor smith has made the whole
second for him so from one point once or
1.6 our members agreed buried thank you
very much indeed like they're going on
to the next item now we're now going
into a private session our if members a
grammar bother to read is something
wrong members or officers here but
normally would include the public from
this